In today's video we'll talk about thermobaric
weapons and their effects on humans but i
make a premise, I am not an expert and I can
t replace those who have made the study of
certain topics a profession but I can still
make myself useful: translate into simple
words, where possible, complex concepts. Let's
start. On March 1, 2022 a senior US defense
official tells journalists the deployment,
without specifying the exact location, of
Tos-1 weapon systems capable of sending thermobaric
rockets against Ukrainian targets. A dramatic
signal dictated by the Russian need to close
the game as quickly as possible, after the
Ukrainians have demonstrated a great ability
to resist to a more numerous and better equipped
enemy. Then the visual confirmation, on the
web are circulating the first videos and images
that show some Russian convoys carrying these
lethal weapons. But what exactly is a thermobaric
weapon and on what occasions has it been used
throughout history? It is not easy to give
a definition, above all because the term has
been improperly used to include in a single
category different weapon systems and to describe
different effects. Etymology comes to our
rescue: the Greek words "thermos" and "baros",
respectively heat and pressure, describe well
the effects of these weapons: very high temperature
and dynamic overpressure (or shockwave). In
the simplest terms, a thermobaric munition
is a type of enhanced explosive munition that
produces the typical effect of a conventional
high-temperature explosion but, by consuming
the oxygen present in the air, creates a much
greater shockwave, thus increasing the lethality
zone and going to hit victims who are located
further away from the epicenter of the detonation.
I open and close a parenthesis: thermobaric
weapon and fuel-air weapon are not synonymous,
they are two species of the same genre "enhanced-blast
weapons", because their operating principle
is different but the effects are the same.
A typical thermobaric device consists of a
container of a fuel mixture that houses a
small explosive burst charge, called "dispersal
charge." After the mixture is dispersed as
a cloud and mixes with the surrounding oxygen,
the charge causes it to ignite, creating a
large shockwave that does enormous damage,
literally crushing personnel in the immediate
vicinity to death. According to a 1993 study
by the U.S. Defense Intelligence Agency, the
methods of killing against living targets
are diverse and brutal: what kills is obviously
the pressure wave and subsequent vacuum of
oxygen, which collapses the lungs, but the
victims will also be severely burned and likely
to breathe in the burning toxic fuel. The
same agency in another paper speculates that
because "the shock and pressure waves cause
minimal damage to brain tissue, it s possible
that victims are not rendered unconscious
by the blast, but instead suffer for several
seconds or minutes while they suffocate."
But it doesn't end there: outside the area
of the cloud, the shock wave travels very
fast and can hit even those who are beyond
the range of the explosion, causing them serious
injuries to internal organs. Think that the
pressure that is created is up to 2 times
greater than that generated by a conventional
explosive weapon. This is confirmed by a study
of the Central Intelligence Agency of the
United States, for which "the effect of such
an explosion in confined spaces is immense.
Those near the ignition point are obliterated.
Those at the fringe are likely to suffer many
internal, and thus invisible injuries . In
addition to collapsing lungs, there is talk
of embolisms in blood vessels, bleeding and
lacerations that can lead to peritonitis,
ruptured eardrums and displacement of eyes
from their sockets. It s not an exaggeration
to say that such devices can have the effects
of a tactical nuclear weapon without the disadvantage
of producing radiations. Because of the mixture's
ability to easily creep into any cavity, there
is nothing that can protect against its devastating
effects, neither natural terrain features
nor field fortifications that aren t hermetically
sealed. Indeed, the ideal use is precisely
against enclosed structures, such as bunkers
or buildings, since the cloud, by sucking
in materials nearby to fill the oxygen void,
amplifies the destruction of the structure's
load-bearing elements. As reported by a Russian
military scientist writing for the military
magazine Voyennyye Znaniya (Military Knowledge),
thermobaric weapons are also effective in
eliminating minefields and completely destroying
the vegetation of a certain area to make room
for helicopter landing sites. In fact, the
US first experimented with this system in
the 1960s in Vietnam with the famous and massive
daisy-cutter bomb, capable of clearing entire
sections of forest. In general, the category
of enhanced explosive weapons has found use
on several occasions: the US used them in
1991 during the first Gulf War, then in 2001
in Afghanistan in an attempt to flush out
Al-Qaeda members sheltering in the mountains
of Tora Bora, and more recently in 2017 against
ISIL members in the Afghan region of Nangarhar.
The Russians, on the other hand, tested several
thermobaric systems in 1969 during the border
conflict with China, then it was the turn
of attacks on the Afghan Panshjir valley in
the early 1980s against Massoud's forces and
more recently, as Interfax reported, between
October and December 1999 during the offensive
against Chechen forces in the direction of
the capital Groznyj. During the Russian advance
to take the city, two main thermobaric launch
systems were used: the devastating Tos-1,
also called "Buratino", which we hear so much
about these days, operational since the early
80's during the Soviet-Afghan war and developed
by the Transmash design office in Omsk. It
s a 220 mm multiple rocket launcher system
mounted on a T-72 tank chassis. Its maximum
effective range is 3.5 km but other sources
say it could reach 5 km. The other Afghanistan
veteran, much smaller in size clearly, is
the single-shot RPO-A Shmel shoulder-mounted
launcher with a claimed maximum range of 1km
and a maximum effective range of 600 m. This
type of weapon is at its best when used as
a "bunker buster" and loses some effectiveness
when used against dispersed troops in the
open field, normally killing no more than
a couple in bursts. When used against armored
vehicles, however, it usually damages the
vehicle, but the crew survives and is able
to return fire. To conclude, it remains to
be understood if there are international treaties
that prohibit or limit the production or use
of such weapons. Unfortunately not, but this
doesn t mean that there are no arguments against
their development: as reported by Human Rights
watch, since the enhanced blast weapons cover
a very large area, they are prone to indiscriminate
use, especially in or near populated areas.
In urban settings it s very difficult to direct
the effect of these weapons only to militaries
without involving civilians, because of their
very nature, and then for the fact that covering
every corner or cr vis make it virtually impossible
for civilians to take shelter from their destructive
effect. So even if a thermobaric weapon is
aimed at a military target, its extensive
and uncontrollable effect doesn t exclude
the involvement of civilian victims and this,
that is the use of weapons in attacks that
can not distinguish between combatants and
civilians, is prohibited by the Geneva Conventions
of 1899 and 1907. However, efforts have not
yet produced concrete results, given that
the 1980 Convention prohibiting the production
of certain conventional weapons deals with
incendiary weapons, in which category, however,
thermobaric weapons would not fall. And if
we look at the current conflict between Russia
and Ukraine, the problem doesn t only concern
the possible use of these weapons but also
of the so-called cluster munitions and obviously
of the feared nuclear warheads. Some suspect
that Russia has already used the former, despite
the existence of an international convention
of 2008 that prohibits them and that Moscow,
although not a signatory, has always respected.
The possible use of the Russian nuclear arsenal
instead, which now counts almost 6000 warheads,
is certainly the most worrying, given the
recent threats of President Putin to use them,
if any power should interfere militarily.
Well, we we are done for today, I thank you
all for your attention and see you in the
next episode. Ciao!